here to talk more about India's
potential and its problems is andreas
Bhairav he consults with companies
looking to do business in India and he's
also the head of Berlin's German Indian
Roundtable an organization that
facilitates business relations between
the two countries
Andres welcome to the show we're so
pleased you could be here thank you now
when you're advising German companies
looking to get into the Indian market
what's the biggest piece of advice you
give them I think we would advise them
to choose their partners properly to do
their homework and to allow a lot of
time a lot of time somebody okay bring
patience now how much of the
difficulties of doing business in India
are related to the culture the lingering
effects of the caste system and how much
to poverty and failing infrastructure I
think it's very very difficult to
generalize in that respect India of
course being 3,000 kilometers either
rain or southeast waste is as complex
and many fold cultures languages and so
it's difficult to generalize I think the
standard answer would be there is always
a difficulty with infrastructure always
ask a city of energy so these are the
two points which are on the
technological side and the other element
would be the availability of properly
trained labor Faja Baida as we would say
in Germany a skilled workers that are
skilled workers properly trained workers
that is a real real as casa T now
India's Prime Minister Narendra Modi is
setting India on a new course he talked
about this at the Hannover Messe on the
weekend he introduced some of his ideas
with German Chancellor Angela Merkel
what do you make of it I think Modi is
very very pragmatic and very well
advised to go after that training issue
and I'm informed that that was the top
issue that he wants to discuss with our
Chancellor support us with respect to
what in Germany would be called the dual
training and blend elements of the
Indian side and of the German systems so
I think he will actually trigger Oh
really has trigger it and you leave
quantum leap in the indian industry
comparable to the one of 1991 okay all
right so let's talk about his making
india campaign for a minute now he's
saying he wants western companies to
outsource manufacturing to india that's
something new because up until now we've
seen western companies outsource a lot
of IT to india but manufacturing is
india really set up for that go step by
step i think and sector by sector there
will be areas where it would be too
optimistic today it will take more time
but yes i think once the interest in
germany grows with respect to the union
potential many of these projects will be
realistic mmm we've talked a lot about
the challenges of doing business in
india but obviously there's a reason
that companies are so eager to get in
there what is india offer investors and
india apart from the fact that they
believe they are very cheap that is
debatable but it very often one has to
take a look at the total cost not just
the cost of labor and then india offers
long-term relationships with a very high
reliability i think once the
relationship is there is a very very
strong bond yes now we've talked a lot
about what india can learn from germany
namely some education and training
what can germany learn from india yeah
this is my favorite theme when I talk to
my German fellow countrymen you can
learn a lot from India that is the way
how we organize our life how we organize
industry how you organize personal life
what our Indian friends would call a
holistic approach I think that is
something we can learn from them the
holistic approach andreas baldra thank
you so much for being our guest today
thank you